my name is Robin Hogan I'm the Deputy
Director of Public Affairs at the
University and it's my pleasure to
welcome you to what will certainly be an
educational and enlightening program
this afternoon during a very sad and
troubling time at Yale I want you to
know that we seriously considered
postponing today's event in honor of an
e lei and her family her friends and her
fiance but Annie dedicated her life to
science and to the pursuit of knowledge
and I didn't know I'd have the privilege
of knowing Annie but i would guess that
she wouldn't want an opportunity like
this to be cancelled on her behalf i
would guess that she would say go
forward this is a part of Gail's mission
of Education and so we decided to do
that it was not a difficult it was a
difficult decision and well I'm sure
there are a lot of your colleagues who
are not here today because of their time
of mourning and remembrance and I honor
that I would like you to join me please
in just a moment of silence before we
start the program in memory of our loss
colleague
thank you very much
I want to acknowledge also that this
panel is sort of the ever-shrinking
panel it started out larger Jim Marrone
from brown a very well-known author and
authority on health care policy was
going to join us until Monday afternoon
when he called me said his wife was was
very ill and he could not come over from
Providence this afternoon also Mike
waldholtz who was 25 years at the wall
street journal now at bloomberg news in
New York head of their bureau that
covers education health care policy
biotechnology pharmacology environment
and education also called this morning
at nine o'clock and said because of the
Baucus bill that was reported out today
his and because his assistant is sick he
could not get out of New York so that's
the bad news the good news is is the Ted
marmar is so adept and nimble he didn't
lose a beat when I called him and said
we don't have a moderator he said I'll
do it and I'll moderate and commentate
and I'll make the distinction between
the two in the course of the dialogue
and only Ted could do that so thank you
head for filling in those two roles i'm
going to introduce the panel and then
get out of the way here and let the
authorities talk about this important
subject let me start with introducing
our moderator and commentator theater
marmar one of Yale's foremost experts in
welfare state policy and really the Dean
of health policy at Yale he recently
retired as presser as a professor of
public policy management at the Yale
School of Management after a very
distinguished career he's written
extensively one might say exhaustively
on this subject in a variety of venues
he's the co-author or author of 11 books
published over a hundred articles in a
wide range of scholarly journals he's a
frequent op-ed contributor to the u.s.
and Canadian newspapers Canada happens
to be one of the areas of focus of his
work the Canadian healthcare system and
together was with his longtime law
colleague Jerry ma sha he regularly
writes opinion pieces for the
Philadelphia Inquirer
Ted lectures frequently on health policy
management and law to both management
and law students he's an expert witness
in cases ranging from constitutionality
of the Canadian Health Act asbestos
disputes and drug pricing fraud Ted
began his career as a special assistant
to Wilbur Cohen Secretary of hgw back in
the mid 60s when I was an undergraduate
at Yale he was associate dean of
Minnesota's School of Public Affairs a
faculty member at the University of
Chicago the head of Yale Center for
Health Services a member of President
Carter's Commission on the national
agenda for the 1980s and a senior social
policy advisor to Walter Mondale in the
presidential campaign of 1984 he has
testified before Congress about medical
medical reform Social Security and
welfare issues as well as being a
consultant to government and nonprofit
agencies capping off Ted's long list of
awards the British Academy recently
elected him a corresponding fellow the
highest honor the Academy was those for
scholarly distinction our second
panelist has been I think probably
quoted more than even Bob Shiller in the
last few weeks about the subject we're
going to discuss today he tells me he's
got a piece up on the wall street on the
New York Times site today on the Baucus
bill again a journalist and author a
scholar he had perhaps the one mistake
he made in his short career as he went
to undergraduate he got his
undergraduate degree at a trade school
in Cambridge yeah but then he saw the
light and he came to New Haven and he
got his doctoral degree in the year 2000
joined the Yale faculty in 2002 he took
a short hiatus to the UC Berkeley for a
year decided you didn't like living the
bear it came back to New Haven as a full
professor this this this summer and
we're delighted that he is back in the
Haven it riches all of us as I mentioned
he is a prolific writer his most recent
book
is health at risk America's ailing
health system and how to heal it which
he edited very recently in his spare
time Jacob is a killer cyclist so if you
want to go for a ride up east rock you
know before breakfast called called
Jacob hacker finally our third panelist
is is someone who is well known on this
campus dr. Stephanie Spangler who is a
position a clinical professor here at
the school of medicine and a senior
member of the Yale administration dr.
Spangler has served as the deputy
provost for Health Affairs Yale for the
past 14 years and in that capacity she
serves as the Provost e 0 liaison for
the schools of medicine nursing and
public health before in assuming that
position dr. Spangler served as director
of Yale health services which is a
health care delivery system that serves
35,000 faculty students dependents and
retirees so she has run a substantial
health care system and is an authority
both as a clinician and as an
administrator she did a residency here
at yale-new Haven Hospital and holds an
appointment at the med school as a
clinical professor in the department of
obstetrics gynecology and reproductive
sciences just this month you may have
read a memo from Provost Peter salivate
that announced additional
responsibilities for dr. Spangler she's
now the associate vice president for
west campus planning and program
development putting a right in the
center of our efforts to craft the
future of Yale medicine and science on
our 136 acre West Haven campus so I am
looking forward as all of you are to
what will be I'm sure a informed and
measured and civil and articulate debate
this afternoon really not a debate but a
discussion this will be memorialized by
two different television networks
Connecticut television network which is
sort of the c-span of Connecticut is
taping the show in its entirety as is
our Yale broadcast Center
so we will ask if you would like to ask
a question or make a comment that you do
so at the two mics at this end the
aisles you cannot speak from your seat
you have to stand at the mics otherwise
you'll just be a voice coming out of the
ether and you will not be on camera so
with without further ado please join me
in welcoming our panelists
well thank you Robin and thank you folks
for coming on this miserable day and
varying with the weather to have a what
we hope is a civil discussion of health
care reform the fateful time that we're
in my fondest hope for this afternoon is
that over the next hour and a half hour
and a quarter now we have about half the
time devoted to presentations by the
panelists and some exchange between us
and leave at least half the time for
questions and comments by the audience
my own view in my capacity is a moderate
and observer of the debate this in 2009
is that it's been to use a technical
term a terrible debate it's been marked
by lies distortions twisted claims
incivility screaming matches and so on
and that's I didn't expect anything like
that here but i also think in addition
to being uncivil it was unenumerated so
that we've spent a huge amount of time
hearing about health care reform and not
learning much about what the choices are
so that's the aspiration for this
afternoon the second idea of really is a
bun of ground rules I'm well aware of
the difference between being a moderator
and a speaker and I don't have any
illusion that even if I tried that you
won't have a sense that might have
strong views of my own but I do have 30
years of experience of weekly moderating
of a seminar so I know something about
and I think I'll be able to control
myself in that role and if I don't Jacob
who's known me for many many years will
actually play the role of a counter
weight to that I'm sure and Stephanie
have I've known for a long time as well
will also be there the ground rules are
these I've got a series of questions
that I posed that I hope we will get to
either in the opening statements that or
not but in the course of a afternoon
they just read them to you to sort of
focus at least on what I hope we touch
on one question that I want to raise is
why did the strategy of reform
of President Obama take the formative
how come we're discussing health care
reform in the light of the president's
claims about problems and remedies
secondly what happened to that strategy
over the last year and a half how do we
understand this is not speculation for
speculation sort it to make some sense
of why in the United States we've had
such a difficult time coming to even a
resolution about what the problems are
and what priorities they would have
thirdly where are we right now what are
our circumstances both in reform and an
american medical care and even more
importantly what range of political
results do we face now in the near
future with what results for the country
under the most likely outcomes of reform
in the next month or two those are the
those are the general questions that I
thought we ought to touch on as we try
to have a civil discussion of American
health care reform the experience we've
been through for the last year and a
half I have to say one more thing way of
a story and those who know me well will
recognize this but as I look on the
audience all I can think of is a true
story that was once told to me about the
difficulties of communicating to an
audience this has to do with the
election of nineteen sixty what John F
Kennedy was running for the presidency
he after winning the primary asked his
staff to get hold of Governor Stevenson
and get him to speak on his behalf
because Steven since it was such a great
orator they finally got Stevenson to do
so he went to Philadelphia it gave a
speech at the end of the speech a woman
of mature years came up to him and said
governor seat brother worship police
said governor Stevenson that was the
most wonderful superfluous speech I've
ever heard and Stephenson thought I
ranee was the right response so he said
to the lady wonderful you know given
your response perhaps I should publish
this speech posthumously
to which the poor dear said wonderful
the sooner the better being clear is not
enough we'll start with trying to be
clear about our views Jacob heifer first
well thanks very much and it's a
pleasure to be here even under these
difficult circumstances it's
particularly a pleasure to be here
because I believe so strongly that the
medical profession and those affiliated
with it really have to be on the front
lines of finding a solution to the
problems were facing just two days ago
the New England Journal of Medicine
released the results of a survey of
american physicians that found that
contrary to sort of the common view of
physicians as monolithically opposed to
government in any form circa nineteen
you know fifty fight against a truman
health plan that in fact majority of
physicians support something that i've
been advocating for a while and have
become identified with a public health
insurance plan competing with private
insurance for the business of those who
lack coverage today or who work for the
smallest firms and I was heartened to
see that in fact about a fifth of
physicians support a universal national
health insurance system sometimes called
single-payer but Ted is always reminded
me that that's probably the worst
description you could possibly imagine
for that kind of system it's kind of
like describing a house by a by talking
about its plumbing and so I'll just call
it medicare-for-all now Ted and I go
back a long way I've heard the joke he
just told about 35 times but it never
ceases it never it never ceases to amuse
as a moderate I'm going to limit you but
I'm the counterweight so and and it
actually is wonderful to have Ted here
both because he has brought so much to
this debate over time over a long long
period of time Ted did not i think was
none of you seem to see the roast and
that one so i'll try a little better
next time and at the same time he was
the person who helped me get into this
field in the first place he was my
mentor when i was back at yale as a
graduate student someone once said to me
that you can divide you
or advisors into mentors and tormentors
and and Ted was definitely on the mentor
side most of the time and and he worked
for Wilbur Cohen which came up before
and so I want to start my very brief
remarks which I've already gotten well
into with a joke about Wilbur Cohen it
it's told and that has a lesson for us
today apparently when Wilbur Cohen died
sadly he went to heaven and was at the
at the gates of heaven and was asked by
God whether a simple question God asked
Wilbur will the United States ever have
national health or no sorry Wilbur got
to heaven I really should have practiced
this joke beforehand Wilbur got to
heaven and he looked up to God and he
said I just have one question will the
United States ever have national health
insurance to which he heard this booming
voice not in my lifetime and I think in
that in that joke Liza reality we all
know the United States has debated this
issue since the early part of the 20th
century and yet we have failed
manifestly failed to resolve it and with
the exception of the passage of Medicare
and Medicaid in 1965 we remain heavily
reliant on employer-based health
insurance private health insurance
that's eroding as the source of health
security for working-age Americans and
their families if anybody saw the Census
Bureau statistics they know that we are
gradually moving toward a system that
where the government is playing a much
larger role than most of us acknowledge
because as employer-provided health
insurance has eroded more and more
lower-income Americans have been
enrolled in Medicaid and the state
children's health insurance program but
at the same time we still have millions
of Americans who are uninsured some 46
million according to the to the latest
statistics and millions of more who are
underinsured who have coverage is
inadequate and that problem is growing
rapidly as well now in the midst of this
debate you may be wondering why is it in
the midst of these statistics you may be
wondering that why is it that this
debate has has so far seemed so both so
confrontational
and as Ted said so divorced in some
sense from a discussion of how we would
actually address these problems and I
think it it comes down to a central
contradiction that was embodied in
Obama's speech just a little over a week
ago in that speech President Obama said
there were three goals that he wanted to
achieve he wanted to make sure there
were no disturbances in the
employment-based coverage private
coverage on which millions of Americans
already relied but at the same time that
coverage was extended to those who
lacked it and made secure and that
covered the cost of coverage was brought
down that reflects the political
difficulties in this country of
challenging the employment-based system
we've come to rely on but I would submit
to you that those goals those three
goals are very difficult to achieve in
practice and just how difficult is
revealed by the complicated nature of
many of the bills on the table today
including I think the quite inadequate
bill that president that was submitted
today by Senator Baucus the Chairman's
mark and the problem really is that the
fundamental changes that are going to be
needed to bring down costs and to make
coverage more secure are very hard to
reconcile with the idea that there will
be no change in the employment-based
coverage on which Americans rely today
and indeed seem quite incompatible in
certain respects how do we make that
coverage more secure without regulating
it but how do we regulate it without
affecting it how do we gain additional
coverage when we know that millions of
Americans are going to be losing
coverage over the next decade without
somehow intruding into the private
system that we have come to rely on and
my argument has been that one of the
crucial ways in which we can move in the
right direction over time is that is to
create a new public health insurance
plan modeled after Medicare for people
younger than 65 I've argued that this
could be a backup for people who lack
secure coverage today a benchmark to the
to press private insurers who are going
to get scores of new customers millions
of new customers if people are required
to have coverage to improve their
performance and third would be a cost
control backstop because for all the
flaws of public programs the public
sector is done
better job of keeping costs in check and
could do a better job in the future
needless to say this is this idea which
remains quite popular not just with
American physicians but with the public
is occasioned some controversy and may
well not be part of any final
legislative package unless there is a
concerted push for it and so what I
would say today is that I think we start
this debate now on Capitol Hill with
every major relevant committee having
introduced a bill really not at the
beginning but still at a very
preliminary stage in certain core
respects and what happens over the next
few months in this fateful final month
of the debate I think will determine
whether or not we have health security
for most Americans or whether or not we
repeat the failures of the past thank
you very much Jacob and Jacob is
introducing both the problem side of it
in the remedy side of it which will turn
to later on and Stephanie you wanted to
speak partly about the delivery system
side of this so would you proceed yeah
well first it's it's really a thrill to
be with Ted and Jacob when I started my
job at the health plan directing the
health plan and encountered a number of
challenges in managing the health of the
population in health care delivery for a
population I decided I better get
educated on what what the policy
framework and foundation was for health
care and and attended Ted's health
policy seminars and they were just
breathtakingly illuminating and I would
go back and try very hard to implement
them in practice and found a few a few
difficulties as I came with Ted had
really exciting sessions where people
presented their works in progress and I
always wanted to offer Ted the
opportunity to then come to the practice
and see if he could come to the practice
a club after i went to the policy
journal club but I come from clearly a
different perspective and and an
experience then Ted and Jacob but I have
really been educated by each of them and
probably it would have been one of those
in the Mount Sinai survey who favored
the public plan that Jacob has has put
forward so eloquently I think it's
actually sort of although it might be
alarming in terms of the civility I
think the level of public discourse
about this matter is actually quite
thrilling and I hope that sessions like
these happen in in many many settings
many many times and that we all engaged
I hope we can tone down the level of
disagreeable pneus as our president says
and and talk about our disagreements and
I've thought a lot about why it's so
charged but also why it's so difficult
to reach any sort of agreement in the
spirit of our civil discourse let me
begin with the point I seemingly common
agreement that that we all believe the
health care system is in need of reform
and repair indeed it's been a subject of
conversation since the turn of the
previous century that said I also also
think many would agree that the term
system is highly utilized to describe
how healthcare is delivered in finance
in this country today you may recall in
President Obama's speech last week use
the concept of ends and means in
discussing the public option drawing
upon that framework which I find
extremely helpful in many of my own
endeavors one could envision the US
healthcare system as an agglomeration of
means to address a multitude of ends
some of them explicitly related to
health and health care and others that
impact health and health care but really
were devised to achieve other purposes
the employer-based coverage is most
notable in that it was devised in order
to help employers attract employees at a
time when wages were frozen embedded in
this system are both explicit goals not
all of them directed at health in health
care and implicit motivations and
incentives some supportive and sumit
odds with and with with the current
system what I think we can clearly say
is that the current system does not
consistently reflect the goal or
comprehensively embed the accountability
of providing access to affordable high
quality health care to the
it states population we don't even have
apples and apples we have apples oranges
and dump trucks with some bubble gum and
baling wire thrown in this system wasn't
created overnight making something this
complex and amazing it is the product of
decades of disaggregated decision-making
in action serving a multitude of
purposes as I already mentioned and
already embedded in the so called system
that we have are the manifestations of
the tensions that are riddling the
current debate we already have both
private and government run public
systems there are both federal and state
responsibilities for payment in our
current system we have a panoply of
provider compensation methods from
fee-for-service decapitation and we
already have irrational rationing the
system is fragmented complex unreliable
and often impossible to understand
patients lose coverage when they change
or lose jobs coverage changes without
consultation providers cannot follow
panels of patients over time when
coverage and employment and ensure
decisions throw those patients right out
of the network my colleagues in academic
medical centers absorb millions of
dollars in cost for patients with no
coverage and no ability to pay insurers
face endless requests were coverage for
the latest newest most expensive and
maybe the best technologies all that
said we're Americans are nothing if not
unfailingly and I think sometimes a
masochistic alee resilient and adaptable
and most of us have struggled mightily
to make sure that we have coverage or
the job that provides the coverage so
that we can see the doctor our friends
recommend and get the treatments
advertised on last night's TV there are
thousands of little fragile adaptive
ecosystems of patients and providers and
even payers out there holding on in some
cases literally for dear life it's no
wonder they don't want to change the
system that they're in but just because
a tear raising ly complex and difficult
is no reason to step back and wait in
fact it is a very good reason to forge
ahead we cannot wait until another day
or another year which will only add to
the pile of non focused implicit
decisions and actions that will further
complicate this
them and likely have untoward effects on
the health of at least some segments of
our population it is likely that we'll
have to practice some sort of strategic
incrementalism but we will probably not
get anywhere except deeper in the muck
if we don't explicitly and embrace and
hold high our common goal and identify
the necessary if not immediately
sufficient steps to get there which is
accountability for the health and health
care of the whole population now with
regard to the current debate mice
perspective I'll get a little bit more
specific and speak for my areas of
interest in knowledge which are health
care delivery and the training and
development care and feeding if you will
of the workforce healthcare workforce
much of the discussion and a large
amount of texts in the proposals deal
with the health care financing system
who's paying the bills what are they
paying for and who by default is
absorbing the uncovered costs in any
event the delivery system not
surprisingly refreshed reflects the same
fragmentation as the financing system
they grew up side by side men most
physicians still practice alone in
partnerships or in small single
specialty groups where they have limited
capacity to deliver comprehensive care
implement electronic medical records or
work with multi professional teams of
providers they're severely challenged by
the revolving door patient eligibility
frequent fee cuts and ever mounting
administrative burdens dealing with
multiple insurers most are compensated
on a fee-for-service basis which rewards
volume and intensity and rarely quality
and efficiency and they lack good data
regarding what good care is what works
and what doesn't over recent years we've
seen innumerable studies from many of
our colleagues in academic medicine
highlighting the differences in care
that patients receive in different parts
of the country this was most memorably
portrayed in in The New Yorker in the
macallan vs el paso texas story
according to Harvey Fineberg the
president is the IOM Iowa Institute of
Medicine in a very lengthy review of
comparative effectiveness research for
want of appropriate studies innumerable
practice decisions facing facing
patients and doctors every day do not
rest on us all
blood foundation of knowledge about what
constitutes the best choice of care one
consequence of this uncertainty is that
highly similar patients experience
widely varying treatment in different
settings and these patients cannot all
be receiving the best care so fever
services based on volume not value and
efficiency but fee-for-service without
any database to guide quality and
effectiveness is guaranteed to be cost
inefficient to make it short and simple
the configuration and fragmentation of
both the delivery and financing systems
leave us with no one at home when it
comes to overall accountability for
quality effectiveness and efficiency of
care while there is insufficient data
regarding which treatments and
procedures work there's even less data
on how different delivery systems work
certainly the cost effectiveness
initiatives are impressive and call for
a whole range of measurements regarding
which treatments work which procedures
work but there's very little research
being done on which health care systems
work I'm pleased to see that that
largely through the public media are
there a lot of anecdotal stories about
guising or mayos San Francisco health
Massachusetts the Fairview Minnesota
clinic which is called the sandbox for
healthcare innovation we actually have
our own innovative delivery system at
yells for the Yale health services and I
as a provider was really enlightened to
see what I could do when I operated in a
different healthcare delivery system a
system that was responsible for both
financing and delivery it took full
accountability for population of the
population of Yale there are no
pre-existing conditions or exclusions
physicians were largely salaried there
are teams of healthcare professionals
who who provide care across a continuum
a unified medical record which is now
electronic and generate data disease
registries that allow for proactive
attention to chronic chronic diseases
and preventive care alternative modes of
care that don't generate a fee and fee
for service practice such as telephonic
care and it allowed basically for
experimentation innovation and
measurement and it's cost effective all
of these models have common themes
integration of care alignment of
incentives
and support for innovation now I finish
very briefly by talking about a little
bit about workforce issues where again
we have fragmentation among provider
groups different credentialing and
licensing criteria it takes a long long
time to train and change the workforce
and without any change in the delivery
system analyst now are projecting
nationwide shortages of almost a hundred
thousand physicians as many as 1 million
nurses and 250,000 public health
professionals professionals by 2020 and
that's without health care reform if we
now expect to move 47 million people
from their primary care in emergency
rooms to primary care and physicians
offices if we want to place
accountability for the assessment and
delivery of care in medical homes teams
of diverse professionals ambulatory
intensive care for complex chronic
disease and accountable care
organizations any reform measure must
have robust provisions for supporting
the analysis and innovation with regard
to delivery systems and structures
including provider compensation and it
must have explicit mechanisms to assess
and address workforce development needs
the training of physicians nurses public
health professionals ancillary health
professionals the only way the current
reform proposals can fortify the
workforce analysis and development I
think I shouldn't say the only way one
thing I note in all of the and all of
the proposals for healthcare reform and
this will be my final comment is that
the only place that we currently have in
our so-called US healthcare system where
we can actually collectively innovate
and analyze is through the public
publicly provided healthcare systems
it's through Medicare and Medicaid if
you look at all of the health care
reform proposals there are indeed
provisions and support for some
innovation in healthcare delivery
systems and certainly a lot of support
for cost effectiveness research in terms
of individual procedures and treatments
but those only can occur in the publicly
supported systems so either we must find
a way and reform to stimulate that kind
of innovation and support for innovation
in the private sector or else we'll only
innovating in the populations over 65
and under a hundred and thirty-three
percent of the poverty level and I would
argue that we're not going to get an
adequate and full picture of what the
needs are of our population so I will I
will stop there well what you've had so
far is a commentary about a debate that
really hasn't finished it hardly gotten
off the ground from Jacob and from
Stephanie you've had a list of the ways
in which the American health care
arrangements fall short on many many
dimension and I disagree with both I
don't disagree because I don't value
their values or their standards but I'm
now going to shift to a 2 speaker and
I'll get back to being moderate in just
a moment what I take from Jacobs
description is that we spent the last
year and a half talking about problems
solutions and politics and we've hardly
had any agreement whatsoever from
anybody the fact that we have five
different bills tells us that we have
not been able with the president's
assistance or the Congress to put a
priority tell the conception of what the
problems are they're widely enough
agreed upon by enough people to act on
and we've got a cacophony of noise when
we talk about something called a public
plan public plan doesn't tell you what
the public plan includes the president
has not been able to describe what makes
a public plan public Jacob has and Jacob
did a very interesting article about the
good bad and ugly in these particular
forms but here we are in September of
2009 four months have been talked about
a public plan and there's no agreement
what it would include whom it would
include what role of the play that's
problem number one problem number two is
we've had for the last year and a half a
rhetorical position taken by the
president that choice of insurance plan
and competition among insurance plans
will constitute both a mechanism of
holding quality to a higher standard and
a mechanism of cost control those are
aspirations not
based on the reality of anybody's
experience the two systems that I know
that have tried to have universal health
insurance with competition among private
insurance plans or Switzerland and and
and the holland and in both those cases
while they do have universal coverage
that's true they have not been successes
at cost containment and if it's true as
the president has said that we can't
live with the cost we are facing and
their projected going forward I think
it's crucial that we speak candidly and
and forcefully to the central fact about
cost control that's so often lost when
we talk about ways of improving american
medical care and that's this that if the
costs are going to be less than you
would have been otherwise the income's
of somebody in the medical care system
have to be less than what they would
have been otherwise a dollar of
expenditure must be a dollar of
someone's income that's a that's an
indisputable fact and unless you face
that and are willing to talk about that
rather than ever choose a prevention
which are great but don't solve the
problem of cost or the virtues of
electronic medical records which may
well work out but won't save cost
necessarily or the wonders of giving up
cigarettes god knows what or become
leaner all of those things are worth
doing but they don't have anything
structural to do with the central
feature of american medical care in the
last 40 years which is that we've had
insurance for some we've had no
countervailing power over the whole
system in order to restrain the
understandable wishes of people in the
medical care world for more income and
every other country that I know in the
OECD world balances the wish for more
and better care with restraints on the
budget for medical care now that's my
view and that's that it doesn't say
either that Stephanie's wish list of an
accountable medical care system is in
any way not to be sought but it does and
it doesn't say about Jacobs hope that if
we had
a good public plan over time it would
have these effects rather it says the
political dilemma were in is that the
menu that was announced today by Senator
Baucus doesn't do much at all about any
of these problems and we've here we are
in September not absolutely clear that
that's the case and with Baucus not
embarrassed the shamelessness of these
characters the degree to which they've
taught what you might call fiscal babble
about this the extent to which we
haven't learned a damn thing from other
people's experience we've had the most
provincial debate I could possibly
imagine over the last year and a half
don't it to the extent we've talked
about any other country it's been
hollander or Switzerland which is not
well known detail in the United States
not a word about Canada except ads by
richard scott of columbia HCA announcing
one one lie after another about canada
other than that things are wonderful i
just want to assure you they're just
wonderful i just wanted to make sure
that we don't we don't have complacency
of any sort and there is a form of
complacency in my view that comes from
holding on to aspirations for an overall
reform that will address all the
problems of cost quality and access when
that's not likely the roads we're going
to take in the united states our
political system is designed to make it
difficult to do that and that's why I
Stephanie said energetic incrementalism
is about what we can hope for but then
if that's true and this will be my last
point and we'll turn it back to to my
colleagues if it's true that in the
absence of a tornado of change in the
political composition of the Congress we
will at best have increments of movement
on the financing of insurance with some
attention of it if that's true then the
central question of the health care
debate
2009 is what incremental steps will put
us on a glide path to getting to the
problems that we've been talking about
down the road and that's the debate it
seems to me we've not had I would like
to debate Jacob not tonight not today
because I can in my rule about the
comparative advantages of having moving
in the direction of lowering the age of
Medicare downward and having a
catastrophic plan through the tax system
for the rest of the population and
having a pincer movement from the young
to the old but I'm not going to do this
all I want to do is make sure that as we
raise questions here and particularly
from the audience that we take into
account that we've had millions of words
written and spoken in the last couple of
years about health care reform and the
bulk of the population is utterly
confused about what the priorities are
what the characteristics are of the
alternatives and have been fed a packet
of distorted commentary by our media let
me just add that last point it's really
important to take into account that much
of our media not all of it operates on
the assumption that if you quote both
sides of an argument you've contributed
to illumination and if one side of an
argument is a lie that doesn't actually
contribute to illumination that
amplifies misrepresentation and I think
that's part of the part of the reason
we're here we are in September the
middle of September and we have a
situation in which today a bill was
proposed that has I think almost no
chance of getting through having had
months of negotiation among six senators
who represent 2.4 million Americans as I
said everything's terrific so let me
shift from that gear into my moderators
role and turn it back to the panel of
any comment they want to make either
about their own or my or Jacobs or
Stephanie's point and then oh I think
I'll open it up to the to the group well
Ted Ted said that he disagreed with me
however I I would say they were probably
on the same page in terms of her
assessment where the debate of where the
debate is
so let me disagree with myself only
because I don't want to leave the
impression that I think that that all is
is lost by any means and i want to
emphasize a few facts that i think
should be kept in mind about how much
progress we've actually made in this
discussion so far notwithstanding the
the shrill charges and counter-charges
and the very difficult questions that
remain at Ted can correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe that no point in the
past has a bill actually a bill for near
universal health insurance actually been
reported out of a congressional
committee maybe the Wagner Murray
singhal bills were reported out but no
one ever thought they would have the
chance of being voted on we now have
four congressional committees the three
in the house and the Senate health
education labor and pension committee
that have put forward bills and as this
brief that Ted mentioned the good that
not so good in the ugly the rundown of
the good they're not so good in the ugly
in these bills that there actually is a
there was a lot to value particularly in
the House version of the legislation now
reverting to my my slightly more
pessimistic self let me just make three
very quick points in response to the
comments so far it seems to me that the
the fundamental issue that it was that
is we were asked where are we what is
the strategy of President Obama chosen
where are we now I think it's pretty
clear I've already mentioned that this
that one of the difficult aspects of the
strategy is squaring the circle is
trying to build on the existing system
while fixing what doesn't work in it
without disturbing the employment-based
Arrangements on which millions of
Americans rely it's very difficult to do
and and it raises and it creates such
perverse provisions as for example in in
senator Baucus a--'s plan if you are
offered employer-provided health
insurance you have to take it unless it
represents more than I think thirteen
percent of your income just the employer
portion of the premium and that employer
insurance is exempt from all the other
regulations that would be subject to the
small group and individual market except
for a requirement that it covers
preventive service
and they did not have total
out-of-pocket costs greater than health
savings accounts needless to say this is
not a very reassuring provision for
those who are worried about the quality
of or the cost of the coverage that they
have today that central the central
political fact with which President
Obama has to grapple and which I think
he recognizes and his advisers
recognized but have had a very difficult
time grappling with is that there is
literally no Republican support outside
of Maine for the kinds of measures that
he wants to be passed senator Baucus
engaged in a Sisyphean task of trying to
attract three Republicans to support
reform Senator Enzi senator Grassley and
Senator Snowe even senators know the
most moderate more moderate than many of
the most conservative Democrats in the
Senate has not yet signed on we are
living in a hyper polarized political
environment that's why the talk is about
end runs around the filibuster within
the Senate and the question of whether
or not some conservative Democrats can
be attracted to end the Senate
filibuster which require 60 votes even
if they may not vote on final passage of
the bill I think we should in addition
to the institutional hurdles just keep
in mind just how difficult it is to
create compromise in an environment in
which there is such a gas gulf between
the two parties and one party the
Republican Party it does not support
some of the core elements that President
Obama and many of Americans the majority
of Americans support to achieve reform
two quick observations I agree with
tennis isn't quick quick okay two quick
observations I agree with Ted about
private health insurance competition
having a limited ability to bring the
kinds of long-term changes that that we
that I would like however I do think
that it's important to understand just
how little competition there is an
insurance market today because I think
it's an important reason for having a
public plan competing with private
insurers the number 26 I use a lot
that's the number of states in which the
largest
private insurer has more than half of
the privately insured population so in
26 States more than half of people are
enrolled in the largest private insurer
wellpoint united health together have
vastly more enrollment than Medicare
does and it's a real puzzle why these
plans with 30 to 40 million members
haven't been able to do a better job
controlling costs but they happen and so
I think it's really important understand
that in those areas of public plan would
be a very powerful inducement to these
plans i believe to lower their costs
last thing i think the most brave
problem we face is not the dispute over
the public plan it's not the dispute
over the subsidies its financing it is
always financing where will we get the
money so there are two equations at
every dollar that we try to save as a
dollar of somebody's income the other
equation is that it is every we have to
raise money substantial sums of money to
expand coverage even if we know this
could save the federal government money
over the long term and how much that is
it seems to me is this sort of fixation
on is it 900 billion or one trillion or
1.1 trillion over ten years is very
misguided but there is there is
something we should be fixated on can
they raise the amount that's required
right and that's why right now the
leading is so heavily on trying to cut
spending within Medicare which has
created a lot of concern and at the same
time there is this just round-robin of
ridiculous proposals to raise money from
taxing the highest and health insurance
benefits to putting wind filled profit
taxes on on providers because they'll
suddenly get money for insured patients
previously uninsured patients just go
down the list right if the Senate
members of the a majority or super
majority in the Senate are not willing
to support some kind of progressive tax
it's going to raise funds it's going to
be very hard to see how this can get
done and that's what I lie awake about
right now surprisingly it's not that the
public plan will be substituted for you
know co-ops will be replaced the public
plan or the dull they'll come up with
some crazy trigger I lie awake just
thinking that there will be this sort of
firing squad over financing wherever
but he shoots each other's proposals and
there's not enough money to do this
Thank You Jake Stephanie I'll say just a
just a few few words and I didn't let me
just alert at the audience we've got the
yep these are moving microphones on the
side start thinking about what you'd
like to discuss as stephanie has her
safe in fact migrate to the microphones
and I'll be even shorter reefer so I I
certainly I didn't hear quite the
disagreement that in your comments Ted
with with what I well then I wasn't
clear enough but I'm sort of violently
in agreement with a with a few things
that you said and also with what Jacob
said actually actually I in in my
experience we we are closer to agreement
on universal coverage than I think we've
ever been and I'm speaking not just from
governmental and legislative and
political perspectives but from the
provider community it has been
disappointing I think too many of us
that in previous debates the provider
community was one of the biggest
obstacles and in trying to preserve the
system that had that has been been with
us for some time and and the provider
community has come forward with a lot of
support for coverage that said there's
also still a lot of concern about blunt
instruments in terms of financing and I
think that without the kind of
information that we need about the
delivery system there are a few
instruments other than blunt when it
comes to exacting savings from the
delivery system and I think it would be
I think we have to go cautiously in
terms of promising big savings in
Medicare and Medicaid without
aggregating the the data that would
cause us to do that rationally
thoughtfully and again yes some people
will lose we'll lose dollars I know what
must be the case but it's not a matter
of opinion if it has to be the case
right somebody must lose if costs are
going to be controlled from what they
otherwise would have gotten period
that's not that that's not significant
grabs I or go down from what they would
have been right I'm not disagree
I'm just saying I just say one
instrument that the provider community
is very concerned about is the across
university is concerned about this right
now too in terms of our economic climate
is across the board cuts without without
sought fulness and and so I to worry
that we're going to need to front-load
the system with quite a bit of
investment that comes from somewhere
other than across the board subcortical
irrational cuts and in the in the
delivery system but with the expectation
embedded in it that the delivery system
will will gather and use effectively
data over time to analyze where those
where those dollars are that should be
taken away and actually just as a quick
anecdote even in at the health plan
we've seen as we've brought on providers
who've worked under retainers or
capitation we've seen them examine their
practices when they felt they couldn't
live under the capitation and actually
modify those practices again dollars
came out of someone's pocket because
they reduced the number of procedures
but but it can happen in and and I think
what's really refreshing is to see the
literature changing to think more about
some of this data collection and
analysis and finally in terms of incra
strategic incrementalism again one thing
I find refreshing is not everybody is
just knee-jerk reactive although it's
depressing how many people are in this
debate because it's usually save my save
mine whatever mine is save it and and
and instead of embracing a common vision
there are some people who do I think I
think Obama's been pretty compelling at
least for some of us in at least
creating that vision that you're you're
heading toward the details of course are
difficult and someone at a conference
here recently described strategic
incrementalism if at least you have to
know you're going to Boston because then
when if you're standing on a highway and
a car comes by going south you won't
take that car if you don't know where
you're going and you're hitchhiking
you'll probably take any car and end up
someplace that you didn't want to go so
I think in terms of strategic
incrementalism we at least need we need
coverage we need a way to stimulate
innovation we need a lot of
data in order to really understand the
cost of the system well thank you very
much Stephanie Thank You Jacob let me
we've got more than a little more than
half an hour and I want to turn to what
I said would be ample time and I was
going to say I'm going to turn first to
the left but I'm not going to write
first and we'll go back and forth sir
thank you as they provided in New Haven
i'm actually a primary care physician in
downtown new haven and i was struck as
we debase of your comments that one
particular phrase which I feel is very
important is primary care and I heard
that phrase once from dr. Spangler and
as a primary care physician recognizing
that the workforce issues are very
important that access is very important
i think i would agree completely that
some people are going to lose including
providers and i think that there needs
to be much more Frank debate on certain
subspecialties potentially who are
getting paid a lot more than primary
care providers I'm active in the
American College of Physicians and
they've been pushing along with the
pediatricians and the family physicians
various ways to try to back up the
primary care backbone of our system and
i was wondering kind of how important is
that it's in a lot of the bills but it
seems like that at times it's a small
part of the bait at the debate but
really not nearly enough I'll fine I
think short my short answer would be
that one thing that i do see arriving at
a point of almost consensus is that we
should be paying primary care physicians
more and specialties less so of all the
things all things not accomplished
during the last year and half this issue
you raise is the one that has got a
substantial level of at least verbal
consensus weather when the fight comes
it will be acted upon as an other but I
don't think you should treat I think you
should say that of the problems of
american medical care the remuneration
of primary care activities as opposed to
super specialty activities has been
acknowledged maybe maybe you two would
disagree i don't know i agree with i
agree that it's been acknowledged but i
think it's you know so vital
important and there has been less
attention than there should be two how
this could actually be done within
existing programs I mean it's it's
notable that the real the debate that's
taken place over the over the public
plan and over Medicare that a lot of it
has concerned issues quite distinct from
this question of how you would change
the relative payment rates for primary
care physicians and specialists and
everyone agrees that that's out of whack
and I that I have to say is one of the
one of the best arguments if you will
against a public plan to me is that the
disproportionate political influence of
the specialties and the device
manufacturers in their ability to to
keep this a payment formula that a lot
of people acknowledge really under
values primary care is you know is
something that really that has to be
dealt with but I do think that you know
the best way to deal with it is to make
sure that the public sector is really
leading the way in showing that this is
where dollars should be and that's why I
think it's really vital that the public
plan be available not just two people
over 65 as it is today but that there'd
be some kind of public insurance plan
that's there for people e4 people
younger than 65 who aren't poor as well
so that's all I'll say on that but i
think that's crucial i certainly think
that that the public's hopes are are
sort of centered on some sort of
accountability in the delivery system
and that accountability seems to be on
concepts like medical home and certainly
primary care and and there are I there
are components even in the Baucus bill
of support to expand the number of
primary care physicians my concern is
the way the system has evolved and with
with the implicit and explicit
incentives is that we have far more
specialty care than we do primary care
so and I was interested in reading there
was a report from the physicians
Foundation which represents a lot of the
state medical societies and those
physicians actually suggested that we
might have to in the short term
shift responsibility for some of the
primary care to non-physician providers
and have the primary care physician sort
of be the grand managers of multiple
multiple non-physician providers I think
the real the real issue is lead time
even if we decide tomorrow we're going
to stimulate primary generation we are
not going to have primary care I expand
as you know tomorrow so am I thank you
you might get this is a convention that
we probably should honor which is to
announce who you are as you speak I'm
dr. David Fisher I'm a medical
oncologist I've been on the faculty of
Yale Medical School for 45 years I've
had my role as full-time member of the
faculty part-time member of the faculty
where I practiced in town and I'm back
at full time now and what I've noticed
is that there's a lot of fat in the
system we talk about some people having
to lose coverage or something of that
sort but there's a lot of fat in the
system what do you write about I'll tell
you our oncology drugs now cost between
two thousand and five thousand to ten
thousand dollars a dose given every
three weeks and for many of them there
are equally good drugs that are generic
that we've had for a long time that
would work just as well but the
pharmaceutical companies justify the
high cost of the drugs by saying that
they spend so much on research in fact
they spend more on marketing on
television and two others those facts
are within the health policy community
are well known what would you suggest
they want to do about that I think we
need a system where there is no
advertising directly to the public but
again I'm trying to push you a little
bit on the political realities we've
known you've known and many people know
for a long well the political reality is
that the pharmaceutical companies are so
rich that they fund a very large part of
every con
Chrisman's war chest for re-election and
I don't know what to do about that the
same is probably true of the insurance
companies which spend an enormous amount
not insuring us but advertising that
they're better than the other insurance
company a reason firstly reason I'm
pressing is that this recitation of
these horrible circumstances is quite
common and the problem we have in
September of 2009 is what if anything
can you imagine being done about the
facts that you just saw well they're
very difficult but one of the problems
is we ourselves are part of the problem
we have now abandoned the history and
physical examination most of the time to
get an MRI a CT scan a plethora of blood
tests all of which raised the cost of
medical care far beyond what is
necessary part of it we do because we're
afraid that we might be sued if we don't
get a CT scan and MRI and everybody who
has a headache because there's a
one-in-a-million chance or one in a
hundred thousand chance they might have
a brain tumor and we have ceased playing
the role of a careful physician because
we're afraid of litigation and we spend
a lot of money on litigation and I don't
understand why the Obama administration
hasn't really taken a hard look at that
they say the course of insurance for for
that are not important but the fact that
we practice medicine driven by that I
think it's a very major problem love you
something I want a comment about that go
ahead no no I'm going to going to be
moderated for now
I'm going to save my book so as I
understand the question is why has in
the Obama administration taken more
seriously tour the defensive medicine
and tort reform is that right all right
well I think it certainly got mentioned
and i'm going to leave the politic the
political climate to you but certainly
he finally mentioned it last week and
certainly I agree with you that there's
a lot of defensive medicine being
practiced and there's also a lot of
subtle as well as explicit advertising
and pressuring from drug companies
that's going on by the way I think all
of the reform bills except I didn't see
it in the Baucus in the Baucus bill do
have some version of the physician
sunshine payment act that would require
pharmaceutical companies to post all
payments to physicians to try to
diminish the practice of luring us all
with the pens pencils and dr. bags that
we all got in training and and that's
that's probably quite a quite a good
addition appendage to the to the to the
bill I think the other so there is the
fear of malpractice I also think that
I'll come back to my sort of my that the
dead can I keep putting on the table I
don't think we have a delivery system
that allows us to aggregate data once a
treatment or procedure has been approved
there's a lot that goes into the
approval of a drug or treatment but once
they're out there and being used in
practice in our fragmented delivery
system and without the kind of supports
to allow us to collect data in an
organized way you have to be even more
defensive because you don't have the
kind of data that supports the less
expensive decision so i would i would
say it's a combination of tort reform to
remove that that perverse incentive but
also information to encourage the best
decision jacob mewhen no i think we
should get some more questions okay
we'll have a private conversation about
how it so far on the right
okay my name is James Lynn I am a
political activist and also a user of
healthcare services I am in Medicare
which is a single provider and also i'm
in the VA system which is socialized
medicine basically and the question is
and the question is or the comet or the
comment is to begin with I'd like to
throw this little frisbee out there is
money to finance health care the
currently the US military budget is
using up almost half of the
discretionary disposable income in the
budget and this is certainly not
something that you all could speak to
because this is a much larger political
issue but I would like to put it out
that there is money given the political
will the question I'd like to pose a
question to you though I said as a
political activist I'm working as hard
as I can and with a lot of other people
to ensure that there is a public option
in the health care plan and speaking
just you just relieved Jacobs of
hypertension exactly slightly kind of
curative treatment I said relieved it I
didn't say cured it and I was the
question you want to pose for us I'm it
and also I'm from Montana and Max Baucus
has been I've known about him for
decades and died I guess Ted Kennedy was
asking God when Max would leave the
Senate and God said not in my lifetime
but the question I'd have liked to poach
for you is to talk about the idea of a
continuing log jam in the Senate am I in
Congress people insisting on the public
option people offering much more water
down furloughs so I would like you to
discuss the possibility of that
yeah okay well i think you know we've
reached a bit of a log jam now so let me
just sort of move over put on my
political science hat and and tell you a
bit about where what I think's going on
it where it might go and the first thing
to say is you know I've been involved in
this discussion of a public option which
i like to call public plan choice for
quite a while and every time that it's
looked as if the idea of the public
plant had been decisively buried it's
been resurrected and I think there's a
pretty simple reason for that the
various stories that we've just heard
about some of the problems in the
private insurance industry and the fact
that it's very difficult to there aren't
many other ideas on the table for
long-term cost control that are being
embraced at all has made the public
option and attractive attractive idea
there is very strong public support for
it compared with a lot of other elements
of reform put the individual requirement
to have insurance up against the idea
that there should be a choice between
public and private insurance and the the
latter will win every time and eat and
so I think that it's at you know we've
seen article after article saying you
know that this is this is it they
finally got rid of it they've driven the
stake through this option and and each
time it comes back so I look at that i
look at this discussion right now with
that with those eyes the central problem
is as and has always been the Senate and
in this in the Senate is a distinctive
institution shall we say right it has
two senators from every state right so
it's grossly malik portion and it also
runs on a largely supermajority system
that's not always been the case the
filibusters become a much bigger
constraint on policy change in the last
few decades but that's how it is now so
you need 60 votes in us to pass anything
of significance in a body where ten
percent of the population senators
representing ten percent of the
population can sustain a filibuster
senator is representing ten percent of
the population if you take the smallest
police pots park populated states and
add them up represents 40 votes so
really should understand that if this
were just the house
of representatives we would have would
be very close or to passing a bill that
had a public insurance option now with
the question is what's going to happen
on the Senate side and I hate to go into
sort of these political science details
but I think that if you care about this
debate I think there are three things to
understand first of all this is a case
in which if there's a sense in which
there's broad support for this among
Americans an active support among
Americans it's going to make a
difference because there are a lot of
centers who are literally on the fence
about literally but on the fence about
this issue second of all the the real
question is with regard to the
filibuster is whether or not some of the
more conservative Democrats or a
moderate Republican like snow that would
that would be conceivably likely to vote
for a final package or to vote to end a
filibuster whether they would actually
sustain a filibuster over this one issue
right it's not whether or not they would
eventually vote for it it's whether or
not they would allow a final vote so if
the public plan can gain support of a
majority of senators and support enough
support among and another nine centers
or so that they would not be willing to
sustain a filibuster over it then it can
pass the Senate even without 60 votes of
support directly for it lastly this
whole debate right now is is running
towards a serious log jam and not
specifically over the public plan it's
over the fact that there is there going
to be progressive revolt over what
senator Baucus is put forward many would
like to do something closer to the to
the health education labor and pension
committee bill and the progressive side
of the party in the Senate President
Obama desperately wants a deal so
there's going to be a lot of pushing to
try to get the Democrats to sign on to
something anything that can pass there
there's clearly flexibility about the
idea of the public plan but it's really
quite possible that there really is a
majority support or even super majority
support for any piece of legislation
with or without a public plan it
at which time or rather they're
certainly not super majority sorry which
time then the last parliamentary
maneuver that should be mentioned is a
budget reconciliation process which he
will not go into but to say one votes it
takes 51 votes to pass something if it
goes through the budget and then the
question becomes what can you do through
the budget process these are the
parliamentary procedural choices before
the Senate and they are that they are
they are they actually turn out to be
pretty crucial to whether the public
plan will succeed or fail but I come
back to my first point and say that I
really think this is a case where
demonstrated public support and activism
about it and the continued argument that
Senator Rockefeller and others have made
that there is really no viable
substitute to it are going to make a
difference going forward now we've got
six people let me ask you to please pose
a question or make a comment that's
brief so we can respond to it and make
sure that people are not standing in
vain yes sir my name is Chris goshawk
I'm a neurologist to after ten years
back out private practice has rejoined
the Yale faculty I would like first just
to thank you all for what is it already
an enormously illuminating conversation
and in particular relieving me of my
guilt of having spent so little time
reading what some of these debates are
because now I see most of them are
superfluous and I have a better idea
where to focus my attention splendid so
the question I have or that the issue I
want to take up is a little bit about
this idea of say specialist versus
primary care really the question being
is it really physician fees or office
fees that are the big problem in this
debate short answer that is no all right
so in so help me please understand in
the large field here of physicians fees
versus medications versus surgical and
Hospital fees and how do you factor in
the that the numbers that we see thrown
around about how many billions of
dollars are lost to do the unit it's
easy to simply get overwhelmed by these
these numbers 2.4 trillion dollars it's
almost impossible to conceive of it if I
put it percentage terms i say
perhaps or eighteen percent of the total
bill that's a large number in terms of
billions but as a proportion quite small
Hospital something between 35 and 40
percent the pharmaceutical industry gets
a lot of attention but it's a it's
something or between twelve thirteen
percent it used to be eight on the other
hand it's controlled by a very small
number of players so that the
concentration of capital has a
disproportionate political impact and
viability and they have more as you
probably know more lobbyists than Carter
had liver pills if Carter had any liver
pills but I think you don't want to go
down that road it's not important
whether it's eighteen percent or
nineteen percent the question at issue
that causes the tension is if you want
to draw more physician students into
primary care about activity and you want
to do so by rebalancing the rewards of
intervention on the specialty side it
engages this loss to one of an
aspiration and again to another that is
precisely the kind of politics of
struggle that we're used to in
labor-management the great there's never
going to be easy you should never expect
it to be so and then there's an
additional element here that's appear
it's this hope that were we to be able
to get more primary care physicians or
helpers to primary care and we've
created something ideally called a home
although no one's ever seen a home
called a primary home that that would be
somehow magic well it wouldn't be magic
we don't have a no idea about actually
how these homes would work is a perfect
illustration of aspiration defeating
actually planning it's one of these fads
that has gone on it it's aspirational II
you know impressive but it's got
actually no structure to it so I think
you're getting here a concern about how
it's really a concern is reflected in
the Massachusetts experience where they
expanded insurance and then fact that
found a lot of blockages at the level of
delivery and I would say the way I put
it in
shell is that most of the Reform
discussion has indeed been about the
financing of care that you could get
it's not about getting care that you
don't have and it's important to realize
that the finance e is in and of itself a
separable problem I hope that helps it
does well that's enough thank you very
much I would like to add one point to
that which is although you may say
physician fees are a small proportion
decision decisions making about much
larger portion of the healthcare spend
and so I think as physicians and what we
can do is think about how we can better
support our decisions in terms of use of
resources so can I throw one no thanks
for your time my name is Jorge Galvis
I'm currently a resident in
anesthesiology and will be pursuing a
career in pediatric anesthesiology
formally yell medical graduate so I have
two part question one is I understand
that at some point there's going to be
some form of reappropriation of
physician reimbursements it one of the
things that doesn't make sense is also
there's a big dis proportion in the
costs of malpractice insurance across
specialties and you know if you're going
to cut income and physicians I think
also there needs to be serious
consideration about choices question so
one is just just along those lines if
there's any real hope for this and that
second part of the question is given
that we're probably not going to make
sweeping changes overnight is there any
role in making changes to areas that
might be helpful for instance preventive
care in the obstetric population women
and children you know preventing you
know early Labor's admissions to newborn
intensive care units launch of surgeries
and costs in that regard targeted
intervention so instead of coverage for
everybody all at once for instance
covers coverage for all women of
reproductive age and all children you
know for starters and then adding to
other parts of the population just for
thought okay well I mean I think what's
interesting is
that's really the route that we've taken
with the low-income population you know
starting in the 1980s with the henry
waxman's / put pursuing expansions to
pregnant women low-income pregnant women
and children and the creation of the
Children's Health Insurance Program in
1997 we're at the point now where we
have a kind of de facto kind of halfway
coverage for millions and millions more
than in Medicare of Americans who are
who are low-income and the system i
think is enormously better than what
prevailed before but the problem of
course is that we have millions more
people who are losing coverage over time
in the employment based system so the
one real one real concern i have with
with going down the route where we're
simply expanding to coverage populations
as we did with medicare in 1965 and to
the disabled subsequently with medicare
is that we don't make that next step
it's not self reinforcing and it's not
fast enough to deal with the erosion of
coverage moreover there's this problem
in our system and I think this gets back
to a lot of the comments we've had but
because it's so fragmented there just
isn't as Ted said countervailing power
on on prices and on on incomes and on
administrative costs and on all the
sources of spending and i would say that
before we start talking about you know
rationing and painful prescription you
know which is the book of the 1990s on
this subject or 1980s i think we need to
just focus I think really on the look
what I would consider to be the lowest
hanging fruit in terms of savings and it
seems to me that that one of them is in
on the administrative side and we hear
all the numbers about how much more we
spend on administration how costly
administration is for insurers but
remember there's a physician side of
this as well because of the
fragmentation of insurance and the
multiple types of and nature of coverage
physicians are spending a huge amount of
their practice time there's been some
documentation of this recently on just
dealing with this multiplicity the other
so administration the other thing isn't
just is countervailing power on the
hospital side think would help a great
deal
it's really hospitals that drive while
doctors make a lot of decisions it's
really hospitals where the high-tech and
expensive stuff is done and also on the
kind of devices and imaging side it's
very and that kind of countervailing
power could be as simple as having a
poke you know here I go again a public
plan they're competing in a lot of these
markets where the insurance and these
flagship hospital systems are
essentially colluding keep prices up
because by coming in and saying here's a
lower rate that will pay for these
services it creates some countervailing
pressure and that's really what's
necessary it's not it's not going to be
possible to make every decision about
where cost control is going to come from
the third area I do think we need more
we do need more data but I think that's
going to take that kind of comparative
effect on the side of it it's going to
take time the one area where it's really
simple is is actually the pharmaceutical
side comparatively the v8 the Veterans
Health Administration which was
mentioned earlier hesitant has done an
amazingly good job because it has a
formulary because its bargaining for
lower drug prices vary it's done there
and it's very hard to do generally yeah
now we're but it's come here to do there
that yesterday a doctor say um you know
talk about rationing I was hoping that
we would have enough time for all of you
but I think there's time for two more
questions so why don't you pose the
question and and why don't you pose a
question and that'll give us a time to
wrap it up and I'll just have to
apologize to everybody else okay thank
you very much my name is David za Latino
and I'm just citizen I'm concerned that
that's whatever healthcare is past is
really not going to do anything to
change the system but it's just going to
be very costly to the public you know
and there's not a lot of I worked in the
insurance industry for some time and one
thing that they teach you the first week
in training is that insurance is
coverage for a group of people the
larger the group of people the cheaper
the cost I see a problem with the cost
of insurance being that the more
insurance companies there are the
costlier insurance will be because the
groups are smaller the larger the groups
smaller the co heavy the question is all
the way it's been spun is that you know
we don't want to go the socialist route
and a lot of fear-mongering has been
around that whole issue is a public
option against American values is that
at odds with an American value you got
the question that's clearly the question
is and that question over here Oh name
is Gohan i'm nimah merida professor of
surgery here at Yale my question is to
have not addressed in any great extent
do you think that any meaningful medical
reform can occur unless the major profit
motive is taken out of medicine among
physicians among the the whole industry
it should it's a thriving industry we're
told by the press and secondly half this
country is against sharing their
insurance of whatever type with their
fellow Americans and I think that's a
major problem that needs to be dealt
with okay it's not that the witching
hour but there's two questions on the
table this is close to the end let me
start with Stephanie you can respond
either those questions if you'd like to
so so I think your question was is a
public option at odds with American
values and I think that's an extremely
hard question to answer because I think
we're a diverse population with a
diversity of values it does not seem to
be at odds with our stated goal if I go
back to my my concept of holding that
goal of comprehensive accountability of
the delivery and financing system for
health and health care it's certainly
not at odds with that goal certainly
there are many details of implementation
that seemed to be at odds with people's
values or else we probably really having
the debate and their interests and
coming to Ernests and and and also I'm
sure that there is some concern about
the public system driving out
some of the profits a motive or profit
opportunity in the system as well Jacob
I want to just first say that I'm sorry
that we weren't able to get all
questions and that this certainly was a
civil discussion and an illuminating
discussion for me it was very
informative to hear your perspective and
I appreciate it very much I think that
the the question of whether a public
plan it would be at odds with American
values has a relatively simple answer
actually no we do have a diversity of
values and yet we also have decided in
core areas of American life where
markets don't work well that there
should be a place for the role of
government and the role of government
that I'm advocating is in many respects
a limited one of providing a check on
private plans that in many cases are are
not delivering the and acting on the
values we believe in which brings me to
the second question about the profit
motive I think this is a really
fundamental issue because if you look at
other countries even those like the
Netherlands and Switzerland that have
relied heavily on private plans what
private plans are is quite quite
different they are Kwazii public and
important respects even though there are
problems in those countries the kinds of
behavior we see on the part of private
insurance plan simply have not been
allowed or have not occurred and so
we're not dealing with a room full of
kittens here with private insurance I
think we're dealing with a room full of
lions and while I think that we need to
regulate private plans to make sure that
they live up to very important values we
hold in common such as the idea that if
people are sick that they need care we
should also i think have some auxiliary
precautions if you will a chair if you
will as we go into that lion pen and
that's what i think a public plan could
provide but we're having a debate really
about what american values are I believe
strongly that Americans do want everyone
have coverage certainly surveys suggest
that but I understand that they're
concerned and scared and I would be too
after hearing the debate of the last few
weeks
what what I think and hope is that if
there's more of discussion like the one
we've had today that people can decide
for themselves whether it's consistent
at least with their values to ensure
affordable quality care for all
Americans I'm going to be a moderator
again and just said very briefly that I
think as with my other colleagues that
it has been the kind of discussion we
would hope on the American values point
though I would just say that there has
been nothing but demagoguery about
American values in this area and then we
should be alert to it the shamelessness
I mentioned at the outset as a
characteristic of a political debate
we've had and there's up there's a
mistake that is common in this area
which is to take frustration with
getting progress as of as evidence that
American values are being violated I
don't believe that for one moment I
think at the core of this discussion
which has not been as well articulate
even by that articulate president is
whether or not access to medical care
ought to be treated like any other
market good that you get what you pay
for or whether it ought to be considered
what I would call a merit good which is
to be allocated by medical need and
seriousness of trouble that clear
articulation what's at stake is a
substitute for the profit motive point
that you're making and I think what
what's so crucial the last point I want
to make is we leave leave this is that
if we had forums like this in which if
someone distorted misrepresented lied or
was shamelessly dejame lessly
misrepresenting the situation that they
would Rovira buek the sad thing is we
don't have forums like that the cost of
being outrageous have fallen
dramatically over my lifetime and now
that I'm now that I'm medicare-eligible
I'm extremely conscious of the extent to
which the young have no idea about what
Medicare was for where I was advanced
what social insurances is a lot more to
be done thank you very much for coming
thank you
you